the jurgen experience the number of
earthquakes
since fracking let's let's before i talk
[ __ ] what's the [ __ ] use bro science
fracking let's find out
it's what percentage of um increase
in earthquake activity what is it
yeah it's basically they're drilling
into it's a more complicated way of
drilling but through this
they've liberated so much oil that we're
not as dependent on if we aren't
dependent anymore
on international oil they've been able
to suck a lot of it out of the ground
but for people that live there
it's horrific like there's a guy named
is it josh fox who has that book gasland
or a documentary gasland i believe
that's his name
uh he he he's been on here before about
it which
this is from inside science for maybe a
year what does that say there were you
highlighted
i didn't highlight it's just weirdly
highlighted already even in western
canada
only about one in 300 fracking
operations causes earthquakes oh no big
deal
300 large enough for a person to feel in
north america at the moment
imagine how funny that is hey man
seriously we only cause
one earthquake for every 300.
we're changing the earth only one out of
three they don't tell you how many
fracking operations they have
what if they have like 300 a day across
3 000 different holes in the ground
which seems like that makes actual sense
it's probably something high like that
yeah dude you know people have these
ranches
out in these places and then they they
have these things set up on these
ranches where they'll
they'll frack and dig into the ground
and
good luck if you have like a water
source that's connected to that
apparently
and sometimes the gas gets out of the
ground it [ __ ] up the air quality and
bro that gets dark they aren't just
small quakes
although fracturing related earthquakes
are chronic
they were thought to be minor but new
research is showing they could be quite
large
and damaging the focus of the study of a
5.7 magnitude quake near
prague oklahoma damaged 14 homes
and other structures in the area imagine
you're in prague
oklahoma you're like at least i can just
sit on the porch and relax we're away
from most folks
and these fracking [ __ ] they
chewed up the ground
under your house like the government has
to decide like how deep
under your house is this still your
house like if you buy a pot of land
and they drink your milkshake
you remember that from that movie let
there be blood he's like i drank your
milkshake
do you remember that you remember what
i'm talking about
dude do you remember
dog why am i going to see you again
you're going to see me anytime you want
anytime let's make scheduled times when
we see each other you're gonna do a
comedy club down in a podcast
most likely i'm definitely gonna do a
podcast most likely i'm gonna do a
comedy club there too
why not be fun for all of us
[Applause]